good morning everyone.
Wait, don't applaud us.
Leave the applause to the next few people.
I am Romain Guy, a representative of the Android Platform team.
This is the representative of the Tools team, Tor Norbye
But you are not coming for us.
You are here to listen to the speeches of several special guests.
That's right
I have recently been with Komain because of the official introduction of Kotlin.
I feel very excited.
You may have already discovered that both of us especially like Kotlin.
We no longer take up the time for the speakers.
Welcome them.
Hello everyone.
that's good.
So I was thinking a few days ago,
The first time I spoke at Kotlin seems to be 4 and a half years ago.
They gave me a room for 900 people but only 7 people
So it’s nice to see more people appear today.
Thank you
Anyway, I have about 30 minutes or so.
In fact, less than that
Give you a whirlwind Kotlin tour in 28 minutes
So I won't explain the whole language.
I will show you as much as possible within my ability.
How to use it and how it can provide you
Some of the benefits, can you?
So I have to try to do everything with real-time coding.
So if everything goes wrong, then there is a Google video -
I mean there is also a video about this on YouTube.
So you can see that
Ok, so we have to start with something very simple that you have already seen.
That is the data class
And I am in a file called main
So with regard to data classes, I want to create a new type called money.
And the amount of the upcoming Int type
I know, don’t say it now.
It will have a string type of currency
Ok?
This is two attributes,
And they will all be interpreted as only attributes.
So this is something you are already familiar with.
It is essentially a data class
Let's continue to compare it with a Java I have done before.
So vertically separated
Let us raise the Java money - the real
Let's go from here.
Java money - look at it
This is probably equivalent to what I just wrote, right?
A JavaBean is essentially a data class that provides two getters.
They are immutable, so they can only be viewed
And here is the data modifier that is doing
In fact, it is giving me a lot of things.
Like a string, it gives me that clone
This is called copying in Kotlin, it is doing the same thing
It is doing hashCode
Now you said, ok, this is great.
Very good, but why do I need this?
Because any good IDE can generate that for me.
This is true, it can
But the problem is that this is the code you need to maintain.
And every time you add a new attribute
You will have to go back and change that code
And another problem you will encounter is yourself.
I don't know, actually, if that code is
Kotl--
The standard things that the IDE generates for you,
Or you adjusted a little
Ok?
So this is not just saving on typing on the first line.
Right
Now all I have to do is continue
Then create a main function
Let's turn this off.
This is Kotlin's highest confirmed entry point.
So you have a public static empty main in a class
You don't need to do anything if you use Kotlin
So with Kotlin, you can put everything on the top
It's a bit like JavaScript in good aspects
So you don't have to --
I want to reiterate that everything I show you today and every function
I want to add it to the file as a top-level thing,
But that doesn't mean you don't have more member functions.
Anything, any category, or even a data class
Can have member functions
But for the sake of brevity
In order to show it to you,
I will put it as the top layer, ok?
So I want to create a new money instance
We are going to name it, like tickets
I will say money 100, will it be the dollar?
I will enter a clear type here.
But in essence what I am doing is type inference
So Kotlin is very good at type inference.
And it will try to infer for you,
So you don't have to explicitly state the type
Then I will say, for example, popcorn
For example, tickets, copy, right?
So basically, what it will do is
Copy the previous and all properties to me
So if I didn't pass in any parameters
It will use the same value as before, good
So I can pass in a new parameter and say
As you know, for example in Spain, popcorn
Seven times the price of the movie entrance
So that would be about 500 euros
Right?
Now I can do something, say
If the ticket is not equal to popcorn
Then println "They are different!"
Then it does this in a one-by-one comparison property
It didn't make a comparison point
For comparison points, we have three equal rights, right?
Unlike JavaScript, it doesn't
A chart that you need to remember, with 600 different locations
And this, by the way, is a font ligature
So don't be confused with that,
We did not introduce new symbols
Ok
So I can go ahead and run this
I understand that they are different
If I change this to 100 and change it to US dollars
Then I run this and it will say nothing to you.
Because they are the same
Ok?
Now, one of our constantly evolving features
Is the interaction between Java and Kotlin
So we have this Java money here.
So I have to continue to create an instance of it
I would say javaMoney is equal to javaMoney, then it will be 100
And it will be the dollar
Then if I do javaMoney, you can see
I don't have any getters
At the time, I did have a getter so I can get the number
But if I write getAmount and finish it
IDE will replace it with an attribute
Because we don't have getters and setters
We just have attributes
So this is to consume Java from Kotlin
If you go to Java here,
Let's continue to create an empty public static main
Then I will do
So let's take a look, I have to declare the type.
Money equals new money, 100, and dollar, and --
Ok
That is another thing
In Kotlin, the semicolon is optional.
And the reason they are optional is
So you can have endless debates about whether you should use them.
We are trying to compete with JavaScript
Ok, so money. getAmount
So I am using a Java type now - sorry, a Kotlin type from Java
So I will get the getter and setter, right?
So idiom, depending on how you use it
This is just a different Java file, different Kotlin files
In a single project, it works well and has no problems
Ok, so let's continue to create some functions now.
So I am going to create a function called sendPayment
It will take the money --
And money -- and it will print out the money
Of course we also have string interpolation
So I can say, issue money.amount
And you don't have to put these curly braces if it's just
An attribute you passed in
As we will see later
So now I can call this and say,
For example, sendPayment, tickets, right?
Now at Kotlin, we also have -
Note one thing here, I have not defined the return type.
By default it is a unit, which is a bit like invalid
But it is not
It is actually a basically single object
a single instance of an object
If it's a unit, you don't have to put it there, right?
So I have to add a new parameter here.
Then I will say, for example, with a message
And this becomes a string and you
Can have default parameters
So you notice that there are no compilation errors here.
Because I made a default parameter
This saves you the time to overload the function
Member overload function, right?
I can only have default parameters
Then do what I want
And you can have multiple default parameters
Because you can have multiple default parameters
And you can take turns to pass what you want to pass,
You can also make name parameters
So, actually, I can say that the message is equal to "Good luck!"
There is money equal to the ticket
And this is also quite useful when in use -
You are talking to the old code, for example some
You can't modify the function, they have 600 parameters
And there are about 500 booleans that are true and false.
This will give you a deeper understanding
The parameters I passed in each location
Yes
I like to talk nonsense whenever I like it --
Clapping
I thought in my heart, it all went very smoothly.
Anyway, ok, let's go.
Edit that, like adult supervision
Ok
Another feature of Kotlin is that
When we have very simple functions
Basically like returning a single value
You can just execute a single expression function
So I explicitly omitted the return type
I omitted the braces, then I just returned the actual function I wanted to do.
Ok?
So, in fact, the concept of expression
Appear in many places in Kotlin
So, for example, let's create another function called convert ToDollars.
convertToDollars,
This will cost a dollar
Money, then it will give back money
Then what we have to do here
Is a time statement, so this is essentially an example
So when money_currency is the dollar
Then we will return the money as we are now, right?
Because I don't need to do anything
If it is the euro, then all I have to do is return it.
We have to do money.amount multiply --
Sorry, I have to create a new instance.
Money, then it will be money.amount multiplied by BigDecimal
1.10, then that will be the dollar
Also, remove the IllegalArgumentException
"Not the currency you are interested in!"
So here you can actually treat a few hours as an expression
So I can delete this return here, delete this return here,
Put it here, then this is just
Let time always return to an expression
In fact, you can even delete the return here.
Delete the money here, and delete the one there
Then you will get a single expression
Ok?
Function of a single expression
Now you notice one thing here.
That is giving me a mistake here because this is -
I am trying to manipulate a BigDecimal with an int
So we have to refactor this
Then we intend to call it BigDecimal, ok
Now talk about BigDecimal, oh, let's get started.
BigDecimal, BigDecimal 100 and BigDecimal--
I like to type BigDecimal
I like to do this.
So we have this here
Now, if you look at it, actually, BigDecimal--
So if I create a new BigDecimal, we call it bd1
Equal to BigDecimal 100
You can see that bd1 gives me a bunch of functions.
Like, divide, multiply, all these things
What if I want to do something like a percentage?
I want a percentage of BigDecimal
Usually you will basically
Inherit and then create your own version
And have all these things, but in Kotlin
One of the features we added -
If you are familiar with C#--
It's called an extension function, which actually
Means you can accept any category, any type and extend it
So I can take a function of BigDecimal
I type the name of the class I want to extend.
Then I said that I want to make a percentage point
And what percentage of what I want to do,
For example, an integer, then it’s going to be like that
let us see
So we are told that this is an extension function
It will have this class, an instance of the object
correct
So I can use that, use this reference.
Then I said this multiplied by that percentage -
Then this must be wrapped again in a bigdecimal --
percentage
Then divide by --
Then another BigDecimal 100
What is wrong with this, it should be a percentage
Therefore, the percentage-to-ratio
Ok, so what happens now is on bd1, I have a percentage
Ok
I can enter a percentage of seven, then that will give me
a certain percentage
And the extension function is included in
Any location defined in the package
So for this case, I have it in com.jetbrains.gio
And that will be included
So you can create extension functions
And we will see that the standard library actually
Composed of a bunch of extension functions
Now let's go one step further
Because I can actually extend everything
So let's continue to extend an integer.
So I will type fun Int
percentOf, and here we will do the opposite
So I want 10% of things, right.
I use money, for example, I want 10% of the money.
That will be returned
Let us see, it will return the money
Then it will be the quantity. Multiply by, then here it will
Quote the actual instance, so it will be like this -
And again, this must be wrapped in BigDecimal
Then divide by 100
Ok
I think I have caught the right order.
If the execution is wrong, it doesn't matter.
Who cares?
Anyway, what I can do now is something like this.
Seven percent of BigDecimal 100
Ok?
Oh, no, sorry.
money
So I can make money - no, don't clap first
Oh, let's take the money I have.
7.percentOf (popcorn).
Ok, ok?
Let's do a little better
In fact, what I want to do is something like this
I want to make 7 percentOf popcorn
That's very good
You can actually do that
Do you see that little creeping thing?
What is the twist?
Alt, Enter, add 'infix'
That would be fine
Ok, so any extension function with a single argument
Infix symbol
And what I did was
Add infixes there
And this is for you to follow
Kotlin creates some things about the entire DSL way
correct
So one thing I hate to do here is all the BigDecimal here.
That is very painful
In Kotlin, when you want to create a value of type 'long'
You can enter a length of 100L, then that will become a long type
If I can do this,
Bd2 is equal to 100BD, which would be great, but you can't,
And there is no built-in
But what we have in Kotlin is the extended attribute.
They are completely similar to the extension function
In addition to their extension with attributes
So I can do something like .bd, right?
Now -- or let us, so now --
Look, it also says that you want to create an extended attribute in an integer class?
Want
So this will return a BigDecimal
Then here, I am going to return BigDecimal,
And this is the instance
In fact, I can convert it into an expression,
Make it easier
So that's it
Now I have 100.bd
So when I submit it,
It looks better than BigDecimal,
Ok?
You can do another thing about the function
Yes, you can extend some operators
So you can extend, for example, the plus operator
And what I have to do is that I don’t intend to enter this.
I have a good little thing that has done this for me.
See how fast I type?
So basically, what I am doing is
For the money to rewrite the plus operator
So now I can say that the cost is equal to the ticket plus popcorn, right.
This allows me to increase the amount of money
Ok, you can do it by adding, subtracting, multiplying.
You can follow some of the built-in conventions that allow you to do this.
Ok
So we created a lot of types here
Let me continue to delete everything so that we can focus
We have created a lot of types here.
Please note that in any of these types I created
I never really specified a type, but you can
So I can do it, for example, the cost of a tile train
For example, the train is a type of money
Then initialize it to a new value, right.
100.bd, then the dollar
Now if I move on and enter the train = null
It will show me an error
It actually shows me two errors
One of them is because it is a constant variable
So I can solve this problem
I have now changed this to be variable.
You will see the IDE emphasize it
So it wants to point out that
This is really something you have to escape
We do not enforce invariance in Kotlin
But we highly recommend it
By default, all lists and all of them are immutable
So I can't assign null values ​​in Kotlin.
Because Kotlin tried to explain this type by default is not possible
To get rid of the exception of the null pointer, right.
But sometimes,
You want to have an empty type, for whatever reason,
You feel bored
And you can add a question mark.
Then this will enable you to assign a null value to the type.
Usually when you work with Kotlin,
You may not want to do this
You may not want to have an empty type
But since we interact with Java, Java can be null
So if I create a function here,
For example, fun javaMoney, that would take the money of JavaMoney type
Then use it to do anything
So for example, I type println money.amount is valid.
So this can be null
It can, if it is one, for example,
Return an instance call of this type of function,
It can be null
You can indicate by adding a question mark
When you do this, you can see the IDE
Will give you the error
It says only safe operators, or double exclamation points
It is effective here because it is basically
Saying you will encounter an empty reference exception
So there are two ways to solve this problem
First, you can say, for example, money, not null
Then do one if it is not null, then continue to operate it
Put this upstairs
Ok
That is a method
Or a shorter way is to use a safe operator or
This is the Elvis operator here.
So now we only say that if the money is not null, then do something.
Now, if you want to have fun, you can do the same.
Then the one said, I know it is empty,
But I want to shoot on my own feet.
Ok?
And you have to be careful
Because many times when people start using Kotlin
They got this little, twisted thing here.
Then they will behave like this, actually,
I don't know if it will become null,
Because I really want it not to become null
So I won't handle the case where it is not null
So I only do that
They ran the app and they thought, wait a minute
You have set Kotlin to get rid of null reference exceptions
Yes
Ok
What else
correct
So let's switch to some other things.
Like higher order functions
Now, you are all familiar with higher-order functions,
This function is basically an accept function
Or return the function's function, and we have these things in Kotlin
So we can enter the list of findEmails user users
Then I will create a new function that is a predicate
So I am passing a function here, right
a function that takes a string and returns a boolean
Ok?
Then this may return the user list
So essentially what I am doing is that I am
Filter on a list of users
correct
I will do this later.
Do it later
Ok
By the way, this later is built in.
You can use it without an unimplemented exception -
Unrealized error
It will do another thing, but we will not discuss it,
But nothing in Kotlin is very good
But we won’t explore those now
It has nothing to worry about
I just edited it.
Ok
Okay thank you
So how do I use this now?
I can type findEmails, yes, then I will say -
I actually have a user, let's create some users here.
So userFromJSONFile
I have some use here, so users.json
So this is actually a function I prepared,
It basically uses json to read some users from the file.
This is a typical data class,
You have seen it, the only new thing here.
Is this also has an enumeration class with attribute roles
Ok?
So now I can enter the user,
Then I will pass in the function
Now I can pass the name function using the row and column reference
Or you can pass in lambda
In Kotlin, lambda follows this syntax.
You pass in the parameter name, then you say, for example,
The parameter name ends with .com, right.
So I get a list of users ending with .com
Now you have a single parameter in Kotlin
You can actually omit the explicit mention
It replaces it with it.
So you can use it just like Groovy
Another thing you can do in Kotlin
Is the last parameter of the function is another function
You can actually not include it in parentheses
So it feels a bit like it’s outside
And this is let us
Create one of the nice DSL features you can even
Do this in multiple lines
So if you look at findEmails now, in a sense,
It may actually be like a part of the language
But it is not, it is actually a function
When we use a coroutine to implement asynchronous programming,
We didn't - you know
If you are familiar with C#, C# will implement synchronization or wait
There are keywords in the language
In Kotlin, there is no such thing,
They are basically just functions
This way, you have the flexibility
Decide how to do different things
Now you don't need to do all these things,
Because all of these are built in
So, for example, if I say dotComUsers
I said users.filter, you can see, when I finish this,
It actually chooses the version that contains the parameter
So I can say that it should be emailed with .endsWith .com
Then I can sort by it.id.
Then let's keep doing,
For example mapping that to a pair of it.email and it.username
Ok?
So all these features are actually
Built in the small standard library that will be sent,
You won't have problems on Android
It is very small
And essentially, they are all inside, the extension function
Above the universal collection,
So you have these very practical and practical things today.
So this obviously gives you a pair
And in fact, you can do better,
If it is not in pairs, it,
So a map, email, to the username
Guess what?
This is just an infix function that makes it a pair.
Ok?
Sometimes I won't explain the entire map.
For example, I just want to say get back a single element
What you can also do is reorganize the categories in Kotlin.
Data class
So I can do something like ID, username and email
Ok, then I can use the ID
And it's great, but the IDE complains,
This variable has never been used
In this case, you can actually replace it with an underscore
So just like this
You can refactor the value you want
Anything you don't want to use is replaced with an underscore.
Then you can continue
Correct
So what else can I show to you?
Ok
So I have some other code here.
If you are familiar with the concept of algebraic data types
It can be a kind in nature
Type or other type of type, like a boolean
In Kotlin, the way we do this is to use component classes.
But before I got into that,
Let me continue to enter open here
Note the first thing here, the result of that user
Give me a mistake
Because by default, in Kotlin, you can't inherit from the category.
So all the classes are essentially finalized.
If you want to inherit from the class
You have to use the open modifier, right?
Now I have used the sealed, sealed
Essentially, this is the hierarchy of user results.
There won't be any other classes,
In any place, will inherit from the user's results
Everything that will be inherited from user results
Must be in the same file, or you can turn these into subclasses
So I can move it to the top and then this will be a subclass
But I have to prefix it with user results
Ok
I just created it as an outside class
Then why should I do this?
Because it looks good?
Do not
This is actually very good,
Because when you are doing something, it's often like you are calling a function
Then you think, okay, if successful,
I want it to give back a value
If it is null, I will pass in a message
Then you get this type,
It contains the value you want to give back when you succeed.
It contains the type you want to return when there is a message,
Then you have to figure it out
Which attributes are applied to the semantics of the error condition,
Which properties apply to
Non-error situation, or you can throw an exception
In this case, you can use
Basically returning two types of functions
Then according to the results, do different things
So here I say, for example, when -
Let's create an instant val, the result is equal to the user result -
Sorry, it should be retrieving users.
So now I can type, when the result is successful
Then we have to do, for example,
We are going to get results,
Then we enter the name forEach println
Ok?
username
Then we have to fail
Result println result.message
Ok?
So now based on the result,
According to the type of feedback, I can do different things.
I noticed one thing here, that is, it has turned green.
I don't know if you see it on the big screen.
But this has turned green
This is an intelligent casting
This is another thing we have at Kotlin.
And you see that when I am doing a short check,
It has been said that this is not null because it is intelligent casting
So you don't have to come here explicitly.
Oh, I know this is a success type,
Let me continue to invest in this to the successful type in order to access this property.
The compiler will do this for you,
This is the intelligent casting
correct
Finally, before I handed it to Andrey
I mentioned it quickly, and,
There are a lot of things you see with a filter map,
All of these are essentially eager assessments
But we also have the ability to make lazy assessments
So I can do val, for example, sorry, generateSequence
Then there are some things like 1
Then here we will do it multiplied by 10, then we will do the value
Now I will say values.take(10), then forEach println it
Now this is essentially creating a sequence
An infinite generator
It will never stop
It will start at 1 and multiply by 10.
But what I am saying here is that I only want to take 10 elements.
Then print it out
What it will do is basically consume it until it reaches 10
It prints out -- go away --
It prints out one side, beautiful Christmas tree
Ok, pyramid, casual, and park there
Anything you have, for example
The user we have, the user from Jason, users.json,
You can say asSequence and convert it to a lazy evaluation.
Ok?
This is the time we have today to show you
Obviously, this language has more details.
Go online and get to know everything.
Thank you very much
I will hand it over to Andrey.
Thank you, Hadi
Hello everyone
So as you can see, Kotlin already has a lot of things to prepare.
But I am the annoying person who added new features before you learn the existing ones.
So I will tell you your story now.
But I need to find a clicker
Is there a punching machine here?
No, good
Ok, so I will tell the story without a punching machine.
So my task here is to tell you
What will be the future version of Kotlin -
Oh, thank you
Now we are preparing for the first big event
Is a platform that supports different platforms
So in history, Kotlin is compiled into JVM bytecode.
Same language as Java programming
So we can run the server on the desktop,
Of course, you can also run it on Android.
And the same bytecode is everywhere
That's why we can run older versions of Android
And the new version
But the story didn't end there,
Because we are adding new platforms
Recently, we have added -
But God does not like the platform -
Recently we added JavaScript,
This means that Kotlin can now be compiled into JavaScript code.
And run on the browser or node.js
So now we support three mainstream, very popular virtual machines
JVM, Android Dalvik, and JavaScript virtual machines
But there are many American cases,
That is the virtual machine is not practical
Or simply can't get it
For example, iOS virtual machine
Severely restricted
You cannot perform dynamic code generation
Or for small embedded systems, VM is not suitable
Or, a Linux command line tool
VM will be a starting tool for a long time
So this is not the case,
That's why we are doing something called Kotlin / Native
It can currently be used as a technical preview
And there, we basically use Korm to compile Kotlin
Into a native code to support binary code that can run on different platforms
Currently, we support iOS, Linux and Mac.
And Windows is still going on.
So this brings us closer to this vision with Kotlin,
When it can run on every component of a modern app,
On any platform you like
So imagine a full stack web application
Both the server and the client are written in Kotlin
Or for example, imagine a mobile platform,
Reuse code between Android and iOS
Or mix the previous two use cases,
Then get a real multi-platform scene
So our vision for Kotlin is
Different models in the same project
Compile into different platforms
Of course, you -- we want to share the code there?
Because if you support so many different things
You will want to run the same code in different places
We are working hard to make this possible
But there is a very important thing
Because before,
Many projects try to unify the platform
And often this will eventually become the most uncommon
Denominator, when you only take all platforms
Available things, you basically
There is only one minimal interface left.
And this is what we don't want
So we hope that you can use all of them as much as possible.
Platform-specific and superior API,
Like the latest version of Android or something else
If you want to share some code
Only then, you must resort to some common APIs.
So now the idea is that you have a common model with a lot of business logic.
It can be written with Kotlin
Platform-specific models work in parallel,
And the two people can talk to each other
So when you need it, you can take advantage of the API platform.
You can use Kotlin code when you need it.
So, today’s point is that our future is multi-platform
Next -- oh
The next big thing is the coroutine
So the logic here is very straightforward
Everyone needs to write asynchronous code, right?
Because the world is too big for sequential execution.
This is our reality, but it is very difficult, right?
Who ever wrote asynchronous code?
There are a lot of hands raised
Those who have never done so will do this soon.
The problem is that this is actually quite difficult
Write order code
Or it’s hard to learn the language to help you do this.
Because language can help you in that area.
a lot of
So basically we have a co-program in Kotlin
How you write asynchronous code
Same as writing synchronization code
So what do you use in the synchronization code?
Loop, if, rest and continue
Something like this, right?
This is the same as the collaborative code of the asynchronous code you are using.
For language tracking
All content, and you don't need to express a complex control flow for synchronous calculations in your code
No callback, no fancy functional structure
It's just a simple old order encoding
Isn't that cool?
Thank you
So the idea of ​​the coroutine is,
You basically have the same abstraction of asynchronous and synchronous
Moreover, a good analogy is
Think of them as almost no threads
Like here is the only code example I am showing you
Basically, a lot of things that were done through threads before.
Can be done with a collaborative program
But the coordination process is very cheap
So on the slide, I have a
Create code for 100,000 companions
Imagine it
100,000 co-programs in parallel, and each coordinator
Wait one second to return one
So this program is done in one second,
For nearly a second, as a matter of course, all the synergies
Waiting in parallel
However, if you try to use a thread to do this, it won't work
100,000 threads can't be memory
That is all
So this is a win-win situation if you use coordination
You will get a lot of performance, so the efficiency is very high
And the code is simple
So the main message today is to learn more about the collaborative process.
Because our future may be more out of sync than now.
So I am almost finished,
If you want to learn more about Kotlin, check out our website.
We have a dedicated Android section
In addition, we will have a question and answer session after this lecture.
So go to the developer email.
Part C. Hadi and I will answer your questions.
Thank you very much for listening carefully.